like i i think it's fascinating that you
know people
that are put into this fixed mindset
where it's all about accomplishment
they totally they don't even do things
because they're so afraid of failing
because that is more traumatizing
than than than doing it and then doing
it
and being successful like the the the
that exceeds
the pain of failing exceeds the joy
of succeeding ooh it's really powerful
you know and it is interesting you know
because even going back to what you said
at the very beginning of like
you know being a virgo sometimes we
don't always you know i don't always see
the accomplishments of you know because
we're i'm so fixed on like the goal and
it's been a journey for me to learn
to see where i'm at and to enjoy where
i'm at rather than just focusing on
where i'm going because that way you
don't even
appreciate like where you're at and what
you've worked that once upon a time you
were working to get here
and now that you're here am i just
focusing on the next thing you know but
no stopping and being like i love
the process because like you said most
of life is made up of the process like
getting to the top of the hill is only
like minutes only moments
and it's fleeting right because once you
get there you are like now what
there's almost like or it's like or you
know with our little disease of
not believing we actually did anything
great we're like yeah but you know
i mean this door kind of got open for me
and like you know i mean this kind of
happened and i got
lucky and you know right right can you
relate i'm like
you know i can blow off some
accomplishments to just like
circumstance or luck
um but uh yeah what was was there
um what would what do you feel like was
the point in time where you had to like
grit up the most and be and and
and remind yourself of just what you
believed and
because you know the [ __ ] hit the fan
and you weren't feeling you weren't
feeling hopeful oh my gosh
definitely i could think of like several
points um
but the i mean the biggest one the most
public one was definitely um
when i went on to america's got talent
2010
and at this point it wasn't like my
first time
trying like i had been trying to be a
performer you know
like for a year i'd been traveling to
random colleges playing in cafeterias
like
doing that thankless work that you're
like this is literally going nowhere and
you know i remember like sleeping in my
car one time just being like
this is so lonely like i just don't know
how much longer i could do this
and then i got a call saying they you
know they'd seen a tape i'd posted and
they wanted to
a tape what am i in like the 90s um
helping me feel relevant they saw my
tape
um but yeah they were like hey what you
do is really interesting we'd love you
to
come audition and i was like this is it
all that hard work this is my make or
break i got this
like i'm gonna kill this and i like
worked so hard and practiced for months
and i went through that first audition
and made it
got to the second phase made it through
and i kept making it all the way until
the quarter finals
and you would think that that would be
like a hey i made it pretty far but
instead
i focus on instead of looking at how far
i'd come on this show being a violinist
that had
never performed in front of anyone more
than like a cafeteria of people who
weren't listening you know
being on stage is like that in front of
millions of people on tv
very different and so rather than being
like wow good job linds um
when i was in the quarterfinals i got up
there
i was performing and i got x in the
middle of my performance which is like
humiliating like just like they only do
that if they like
hate what you're doing it's not like oh
it's okay like we hated it so much that
i got x
and i just remember standing there
talking to them on live tv
after my performance and just listening
to them say these things to me that were
just like
so hurtful and trying not to cry on
national television just being
like and in my mind i'm like i told
every friend i've ever met to watch
tonight and to vote for me like oh my
gosh i was humiliated
um and i just i remember getting off
that stage and thinking
i will never step on stage again i can't
face that like
it was horrifying and you know i cried
for hours like
you know and that feels like days and
you know finally after like
a few months the pain inside of me i
wouldn't say it turned into like i'm
gonna prove them wrong
maybe a little bit but also there was
just that inner voice that became
stronger than the pain stronger than the
embarrassment
became the voice of saying you're not
done yet
like and i really do feel so much that
you know i relate it to spirituality and
like
my relationship with god but i believe
we all have like some kind of an inner
voice
and if you listen to it it won't lead
you astray and it
get getting stronger and stronger and i
just like
shoot this journey it's not done like i
need to keep trying and so i did i got
back up on stages i didn't even know
what the heck to do at this point i was
out of ideas but
just by stepping on little open mic
night stages again
the opportunity found me not there
anything i did
like it's just i kept taking the bait
wherever i could find it till i finally
bit on the right one